alors effectivement quelqu'un bluffer
une surprise dans l'émission programmée
dimanche soir sur tf1 la chanson ça
dimanche soir samedi soir samedi soir
par derniers mois sur ses panna cotta
d'accord oui et donc il est apparu très
ému dans la bande annonce de la deuxième
édition de la chanson secrète qui sera
diffusé le 14 septembre prochain sur tf1
regardez et on va vous dire pourquoi il
a pleuré
[Musique]
jean luc reichmann surpris est rattrapé
par l'émotion c'est dans la chanson
secrète bientôt sur tf1 rappelle le
principe on rappelle le principe c'est
quelqu'un il va faire une chanson pour
cette 15 quelqu'un qui vit de terre moi
je supporte non mais c'est de la
pornographie la crim 1 alors j'ai
compris premier moule deuxième temps
avec les larges avec la crim avec une
arme non mais moi je pleure beaucoup
c'est pour ça que je vais au cinéma
soeur séverine wesh porno l'onglet je
tombais cinéma mais ça ne viendrait pas
à l'idée de dire venue filmer là au
moment où jamais cessé d émotion alors
ne vous le dit les chaînes de télé
recherche ça de plus en plus puissantes
télévision en voyant cette émission la
chanson secrète aussi va faire un mal
être
ils vont faire un autre truc la boîte à
secrets ils sont vachement dans ce qu'on
appelle les mots times
c'est à dire l'émotion dans l'univers
qu'il soit devenu ça vous dérange moins
vraiment ça me dérange ça vous dérange t
d qui est bien dans ma lettre c'est que
ça va ça va concerner aussi des inconnus
que là ils sont des surprises entre
stars on cherche absolument à ce que la
terre n'est pas très méchant
j'suis pas fan d'accord et sauber fait
pas pleurer banon de voir des stars
auraient entre elles moi je préfère voir
des inconnus peu arrêtez moi je vais
vous dire moi moi que ce soient des
stars ou des inconnus
les larmes d'une personne ça me touche
toujours pas prévue dans cette émission
un grand moment d'émotion c'était nikos
aliagas
mais c'était pas aussi aimerait aussi à
ma grand mère aussi à manger des
cacahuètes pas être mauvaise langue mais
ce cd très bons clients pour la
télévision jean luc reichmann il sait
très bien que c'est ce qu'on attend de
lui ou des départs il ya vraiment émue
celle là qui me paye se règlerait mais
disons qu'il les a pas retenus islas
vous avez déjà pleuré parce que vous il
paraît que vos larmes sont plus grosses
que vos yeux c'est vrai pour le coup pas
mal marché sur tf1 c'est un des rares
programmes qui a marché c'était diffusé
pendant les fêtes de noël oui la de noël
oui et et il aime le ferait même été
exportées exportés à l'étranger
d'accord mais vous aimez cette édition
non moi j'aime pas du tout mais ça vous
dérange les gens qui plaît non mais
parce qu'on l'abhorré ou qu'on l'a
beaucoup vu mais c'est vrai que c'est un
bon entraîneur et que je suis pas
sensible à sa merci oui je trouve que
vous êtes une belle bande de fous qui
parce que ici bravo
[Applaudissements]
voilà je suis d'accord avec vous au
public ce job d'été on voit leur maman
et on voit leurs frères et aux pleurs et
on est nu et ulrich naulleau que
l'intimé est universel finalement mais
le connais tu devrais je le ramène à ton
âge tu intime je le garde pour moi j'en
fais pas un spectacle
oui on viendrait pas libre et surpris de
participer à sa voix chacun c'est
universal clamé bien sûr mêlée mais oui
mais vous vous aimez bien voulu radine
bizarrement je croyais pas que vous
alliez mais j'aurais l'émission passe
confection konya très déçu cherche la
grâce à vous je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose quand même d'universel et que
forcément moi la musique ça peut évoquer
des souvenirs aussi qu'ils vont me
bouleverser sa molette parfois j'ai
réécouté rené la taupe chez ton je suis
mignon mignon mais groulx avait pensé à
vous jour la tête de ma mère
[Musique]
il avait raison naulleau il avait raison
bah voilà là où gérald la raison et
paradoxalement je suis pas d'accord avec
toi il ya malgré tout un effet miroir
malgré tout même si ce sont des stars
qui pleure malgré tout ça nous renvoie à
nos propres histoires s'il pleure parce
que il a perdu un père ou si elle pleure
parce qu on va nous mêmes autre songé
sur la question on va peut être nous
mêmes ressent gers ont joué au père
qu'on a vécu ou bien aux retrouvailles
qu'on aurait même on espérerait avoir je
crois qu'il rate est la question la
question préfèrent regarder sur leur
portable
au lieu de faire crac tagada dessous
non
[Applaudissements]
vraiment une question de valeurs dont
treize agressions tout ça leur donnera
la question coquine à date heure précise